e aí gente beleza ita misericórdia
vamos lá é como controlar aquilo que nos
controla né
é parece uma uma coisa meio estranha o
que vou falar agora mas essa definição é
a definição mais operação existe do que
a liberdade liberdade a capacidade de
controlar aquilo que nos controla do
ponto de vista do senso comum as pessoas
costumam imaginar que liberdade é a
capacidade de fazer tudo o que eu quiser
né
só que tem dois problemas nessa
afirmação o primeiro é o que é tudo né
tudo depende de um espaço histórico
antropológico social político biológico
e econômico no qual você está inserido
quer você queira ou não né é o segundo
problema é para além da questão do tudo
é a questão do qualquer coisa eu não
posso querer alguma coisa que não existe
o que eu nem consigo imaginar então o
controle ele sempre existe desde o
início da nossa existência porque nós
somos tratados nós temos um tempo né
transformando a esse essa definição
mesmo que você não acredite que essa é
uma boa definição razoável não
suficiente mas razoável de liberdade
eu vou dar uma uma temática um pouco
mais poética né
baseada num nessa afirmação que muita
gente deve ter vindo por aí né postos
criados em gaiolas acreditam que voaram
uma doença
você deve ter ouvido eu falar alguma
coisa motivacional sei lá só que
explodia positiva mas enfim é essa
afirmação ela é razoável até a página
dois têm uma palavra aí que é uma coisa
que eu quero discutir que a idéia de
gaiola
as pessoas pensam gaiola de um ponto de
vista muito concreto não estou preso
estou limitado né
mas muitas vezes aquilo que nos limita
nos dá significado e isso é o primeiro
exercício de controle que em última
análise pode nos dar algum senso de
liberdade
eu quero tratar com essa idéia do da
gaiola com vocês
para isso vou usar dois conceitos da
psicologia que parece parece que não é
da psicologia
são é são dois conceitos importantes da
psicologia que são os conceitos de
decisão a escolha né as pessoas de novo
no senso comum elas acham que decidir
escolher são meios sinônimos
aí eu decidi isso ou escolher aquilo é
meio que a mesma coisa
são fundamentalmente diferentes do ponto
de vista científico
você decide e escolher não tem nada a
ver uma coisa com a outra e é isso que
eu quero mostrar pra vocês tá dando uma
definição inicial que é decidir
decidirem implica trabalhar com a mente
são atributos mentais
os elementos da decisão estão na sua
cabeça a escolha implica necessariamente
comportamento
você só você só escolhe depois ter
escolhido por exemplo a gente vai ter um
almoço daqui a pouco é onde eu vou
almoçar no local há no local b
quando você algum dia você está com fome
está pensando sobre isso você está
decidindo tá você não foi lá ainda comer
portanto é que você pode pensar em você
pode decidir em comer no lugar a mas no
lugar b e chegando lá porque eu vim aqui
né isso acontece o tempo inteiro com
todas as pessoas é algo normal
uma história interessante que é comum a
todo mundo que a gente está na internet
você tá na internet às vezes num site
qualquer de compra de qualquer coisa
roupa livro e tal
você tá lá andando no site e de repente
você vê várias coisas que você gosta e
começa a comprar nem coloca na sua 6ª
virtual né
aí você repara que depois de meia hora
lá mexendo no site a sua sexta visita ao
estatuo grande tão cara que vai precisar
do pib de um país para pagá lá né
e aí quando ao invés de chegar apertar o
botão pagar você vai e fecha a janela
esse é um exercício de decisão que não
se a substância em escolha a gente tem o
contrário também já aconteceu comigo
mesmo eu fui um dia no numa farmácia né
compram xampú pessoas carecas precisão
nos acham porque é careca sabe né
eu fui comprar o xampu anticaspa dia tem
caso ainda fui lá e cheguei em treinar
drogaria já ali já foi na prateleira
peguei o frasco do do xampu e me chamou
atenção um dado que estava no frasco
estava
ter escrito assim é avaliado
positivamente por 97% dos usuários
falei nossa como eles fizeram essa
pesquisa 97% enquanto cientista ficou
olhando 27 por se concretizar essa
pesquisa anísio andando assim né eu vi o
bicho tinha um asterisco de novo aí tava
escrito assim baseado na percepção de
uso de 20 voluntários como eles colocam
isso no frasco 20 voluntários decidem
tudo que milhares de pessoas que usam
esse xampu aqui escolheram como assim
que pesquisa esquisita né eu pensei
comigo mesmo se andando quando percebeu
olhe para trás já tinha saído da
drogaria tinha comprado ou seja eu já
tinha escolhido que tinha comprado e não
isso não afetou em nada minha decisão eu
tô aqui eu usei todo o campo até o final
eu já tinha comprado ou seja toda toda
essa informação do marketing do produto
não adiantou em nada no meu processo
porque já tinha escolhido já tinha
emitido comportamento desde o início né
vamos transformar isso de uma forma mais
ainda operacional
quando você fala de decisão isso é
teoria mesmo tá
quando você fala de decisão
necessariamente você tem opções o que
você prefere a ou b pode ter mais opções
tá cada opção cada produto da coisa que
você escolhe o que esse produto pode ser
coisas a quaisquer coisas têm um valor
que em geral monetário mas pode ter um
valor de qualquer tipo sentimental e uma
probabilidade de você a tribo que você
atribui a esse valor a esse produto
tá é normalmente por teoria de
probabilidade a gente sabe que se eu
tenho duas opções uma delas tem uma
probabilidade p
a outra tem 1 - p né porque em geral em
teoria de probabilidades as
probabilidades são 100% né
os valores são valores monetários em
geral tá no entanto as teorias de
decisão já tem 200 e poucos anos já de
existência mostram pra gente que
objetivamente as coisas têm um preço e
uma probabilidade mas subjetivamente
dentro da nossa cabeça a gente converte
os valores monetários e um valor
subjetivo e as probabilidades a gente
também converte num valor subjetivo cuja
soma não dá um pode dar mais ou pode dar
menos porque a gente isso nós somos
seres visados é isso é bem interessante
em relação à noção de valor monetário
por exemplo imagine que tem uma nota de
cem reais
tá essa nota de 100 reais ela vale cem
reais operacionalmente todo mundo
percebe uma nota de cem reais como tendo
um valor sem tá no entanto o valor
subjetivo que cada um de vocês atribui
essa nota é diferente mas não é porque
vocês percebem 100 reais como 100 reais
de forma diferente é porque o zero de
vocês é diferente
se nada durante a vida de vocês você
passou por privação o seu zero está num
lugar
se você nunca passou por privação na sua
vida o seu 0 está em outro logo a
distância relativa que você tem entre os
zero e os 100 reais é diferente
o dinheiro não tem valor diferente entre
as pessoas
o zero sim ta e logo é a gente cria uma
equação que a chamada só de prospecto né
o ganhador de prêmio nobel desenvolver
essa equação que não é a inflação que os
economistas usam porque eles não não
sabe fazer um experimento né
mas na verdade a gente tem os valores
esses valores são convertidos em valores
subjetivos e agente os experimentos para
determinar isso as probabilidades são de
compostas em probabilidades subjetivas
mais uma constante de o sincravesc do
indivíduo que diz respeito a 10 dele né
baseado nessa equação de prospecto vou
ter um valor de prospecto para opção lá
e prá opção b com o valor é maior e onde
eu tenho uma maior probabilidade de
decidir então as teorias de decisão elas
tentam buscar uma regra normativa uma
regra geral pela qual as pessoas decidem
já escolher é completamente diferente
os teóricos da escolha partem do
pressuposto que eu não quero saber o que
tem na sua cabeça eu não quero saber o
que você fala não importa o seu relato
verbal
você só escolhe depois de ter escolhido
a escolha depende do seu comportamento
observado
tá então como eu não vou te perguntar
nada como
pensei o valor das coisas eu sei o
porquê das coisas pelo quanto você se
comporta para ter aquele objeto
então por exemplo eu não vou te
perguntar o que você acha do produto a
ou b
eu vou filmar você na loja e ver quantas
vezes você vai na loja e quantas vezes
você escolhe cada um deles
se por exemplo em 25 por cento das vezes
que você vai na loja você compra o
produto a em 75 por cento das vezes que
você vai na loja você compra o produto b
eu posso dizer que você tem quatro vezes
mais preferência do b em relação à logo
valor subjetivo é quatro vezes maior
você culpa os valores observados os
valores comportamentais ao invés do
valor do dinheiro te dá uma vantagem que
é 10 porque eu sei um valor de um
produto em relação ao outro
logo estou controlando isso pelo 10 e 15
crítico de cada um e se uma grande
vantagem
a outra característica é a percepção da
probabilidade né como eu percebo
probabilidade sempre perguntar e aí é um
truque bacana que é o seguinte que é a
noção de tempo percepção de tempo coisas
que pra você acontecem com um espaço de
tempo grande entre a ocorrência ea
ocorrência b
você percebe isso como e nos provável
coisas que acontecem com um delay
pequeno você percebe com uma
probabilidade alta exige uma paridade
entre percepção de impueiras excepção de
probabilidade e de novo isso pode não
somar um né
então se eu combinar o valor
comportamental que você dá pra uma opção
em relação à outra combinado a sua
percepção de tempo eu tenho uma equação
chamada função de feedback né que isso é
estudado na psicologia é na psicologia
experimental de forma corrente e aí
criou se duas áreas que por durante
décadas brigam né então os teóricos da
decisão em geral são os economistas que
não sabe fazer o experimento os teóricos
da escolha em geral são psicólogos que
não sabe fazer conta e aí cria-se uma
cisão que na verdade uma falsa dicotomia
né
infelizmente a partir dos anos 2000 e
começou a juntar felizmente para tornar
isso ainda mais palpável para todos
6 na verdade isso reflete muito a nossa
vida porque ó a escolha é o seguinte eu
estou me comportando né eu estou eu só
escolhi depois de ter escolhido eu só
percebi minha escolha quando eu olho
para o passado porque eu só sei que
escolhi depois de ter emitido o
comportamento
então é como se estivesse vivendo minha
vida de repente eu paro olha para trás
vê que o produto de comportamento e cria
um sentido
baseado nesse sentido que eu criei eu
crio uma regra normativa para tentar
prever o futuro é assim que decisão
escolher trabalham de forma conjunta
dentro da cabeça de todos nós temos dois
sujeitos que é o sujeito da decisão e o
sujeito da escolha a saber é na decisão
a gente trabalha com atributos mentais
tá tudo bem da sua cabeça o decisor né
e aí a gente tem o sujeito da ciência
que aquele sujeito que quer buscar a
regra normativa para viver a vida dele
né
então o sujeito da ciência sempre olha o
que ele conseguiu de conhecimento cria
uma regra normativa prevê o futuro
o sujeito da experiência é o sujeito
sensível ao tempo é o sujeito que olha
para trás e baseado em coisas que ele
vivenciou ele tenta criar o sentido da
existência dele né
na verdade dentro da cabeça de vocês
você tem esses dois sujeitos que
infelizmente nos dias de hoje
ambos sofrem por razões diferentes mas
ambos sofrem levando o indivíduo
sofredores como nós né
hoje em dia a coisa principal o
principal problema para o sujeito da
ciência e o sujeito da experiência
o sujeito da experiência ele sofre com
uma coisa chamada associação espaço
tempo
isso é o seguinte principalmente por
causa da internet né 35 anos atrás
quando a internet não era algo tão
corrente o que a gente tinha eu podia
por exemplo vou me encontrar com ela
eu nem conheço ela oi eu vou encontrar
com ela né então por exemplo eu posso
chegar pra ela a gente vai se encontrar
seu eu olho para ela falar hoje está
chegando e falou eu estou a um
quilômetro de você
eu uso uma dimensão de espaço ou eu
estou há 10 minutos de você
principalmente a mesma coisa você falar
que você está há um certo tempo de
distância uma certa um certo valor em
metros que
o metros seria a mesma coisa quando o
senado uma cartinha para alguém talvez
as pessoas aqui mandar uma carta ao
tribunal uma missiva para alguém né
em geral essa carta tem que percorrer
uma distância física então tempo espaço
sempre foram conectados exceto quando a
internet surgiu quando encerrar a
internet surgiu eu posso está hoje em
dia eu posso estar a mil quilômetros de
uma pessoa mas ela recebe a informação
na mesma hora se é um problema para o
sujeito da experiência que precisa de um
tempo para parar e olhar pra trás e cria
um sentido hoje em dia fala uma coisa na
internet tem o mundo inteiro falando
mesmo o mesmo tempo você está afogado de
tanta informação e você não consegue
parar simplesmente pra trás e ver o que
o que você faz da sua vida
então o sujeito da experiência
massacrado pela questão da dissolução
espaço tempo
temos também a questão do sujeito da
ciência que esse sujeito que cria regras
para tentar prever a realidade que é a
idéia da formação para o trabalho
isso é uma coisa que já tem os 200 anos
da então tv a revolução francesa a
partir da revolução francesa tivemos a
revolução industrial
e aí foi necessário que as pessoas
passassem a cisco design o modelo de
escolarização que a gente tem que eu fui
submetido vocês também não é um modelo
emancipatório é um modelo que serve para
fazer o operário tá então uma coisa
muito importante
dodô pós revolução francesa é que com a
industrialização e precisava formar
pessoas que saboya soubessem ler
soubessem contar para trabalhar nas
empresas
e aí o que aconteceu eu massifica
educação algo extremamente importante
para o desenvolvimento da tecnologia foi
algo extremamente útil
mas você reduz a pessoa lógica do
trabalho ela vive uma vida que ela não
merece viver porque ela naturalismo
trabalho como algo que todo mundo deve
ter muitos de vocês fizeram acho que
todo todo todos vocês na verdade fizeram
ensino superior é ensino fundamental e
médio
eu acredito que alguns de vocês pensam
isso eu aprendi as coisas do colégio nem
lembro mais porque porque vocês porque
você não lembra mais das coisas que
aprendeu no colégio porque você estudou
no colégio não prender vocês tudo para
passar no vestibular porque quando vai
passar no vestibular você faz uma
faculdade tem um emprego
alguém na vida isso é construído
isso é uma estrutura social e
antropológica que tem coisa mais ou
menos 200 anos não muito mais que isso
isso mata o sujeito da ciência porque
você se define como de exatas humanas
biológicas e você joga o bebê junto com
a água quando você define assim né a
formação científica não ela prescinde de
uma área de conhecimento
tem que integrar todas as áreas do
conhecimento então veja que somos
sujeitos que sofridos por essas duas
razões
e agora o que podemos fazer para
controlar isso e contexto antropológico
e histórico econômico biológico
psicológico que nos controla né
temos duas saídas possíveis não adianta
nada apresentar o problema zero na saída
foi muito angustiante
então uma das uma primeira saída seria a
ciência como uma nova pedagogia o método
científico não é coisa que senti esta
faz o método científico uma coisa que
todo mundo faz
só que você não percebe que faz a o pop
e costumava dizer o seguinte você quer
ser cientista eu quero então dica você
vai abrir mão de duas coisas da certeza
e da verdade
se você faz uma coisa pra achar que você
tá certo o que você busca a verdade
abra uma igreja tá se você quer ser
cientista você tem que lidar com a
incerteza ea dúvida necessariamente a
gente está na faculdade de engenharia
alguns de vocês devem ter tido aula de
processos estocásticos por exemplo e de
áreas ligadas às séries temporais coisas
dos modelagem matemática
qual é o objetivo de um modelo
matemático é você descobrir o melhor
modelo
todos os modelos são ruins mas alguns
são úteis já dizia jorge box na verdade
então o objetivo da modelagem não é
descobrir o modelo verdadeiro o correto
você não tem como acessar isso mas
descobriu - errado
se você transformar isso numa pedagogia
isso vai ter um impacto central na
maneira como os indivíduos se percebe
porque se eu viver minha vida em função
de minimizar meu erro
ao invés de tentar buscar um acerto
eu vou parar de acreditar em pequenas
verdades que as pessoas me dão e quando
consigo quantificar o meu erro
o processo decisório ou de escolha isso
me dá autonomia porque eu consigo
quantificar o com errado eu estou em
cada momento né
isso me dá uma saudade porque sei que
estou errado isso me dá autonomia porque
eu consigo ter confiança suficiente de
que eu aguento back caso as coisas derem
errado
isso me dá resignação em viver uma vida
que faz sentido né
essa seria a ideia de uma ciência como
uma pedagogia ciência não é um método
feito para a cientista da universidade
a ciência tem que ser usada para todo
mundo você tem que viver em função do
seu erro
você tem que viver em quanto mais você
erra mais você aprende não é que a
inteligência artificial usa porque ela
faz isso porque a gente tem que fazer
assim né ea segunda saída que é
decorrente dessa é a ideia de da palavra
a palavra como mediador
uma coisa que nos torna diferentes de
outros poucas coisas nos diferenciam das
outras espécies que habitam a terra
tá mas uma das coisas que mais nos torna
diferentes é a idéia da linguagem
nós somos os organismos que têm a
linguagem mais desenvolvida
a idéia da palavra como mediador entre o
sujeito da experiência o sujeito da
ciência é algo que cria significado
eu tenho muita convicção infelizmente
que praticamente todos vocês não têm com
alguém ou algum grupo o qual você
consegue conversar de forma franca
infelizmente eu acredito que a grande
maioria de vocês não têm alguém você
consegue trocar idéia de verdade né isso
coisa que falta para as pessoas
eu acho que muito mais por sorte do que
merecimento eu pelo menos durante minha
trajetória desenvolvi ou descobrir eu
fui descoberto por vários grupos de
pessoas que me dão esse espaço de
continência o código será o mesmo
mostrar eu errei eu não sei o que fazer
eu estou perdido minimizar o erro em
função disso aprender criar uma regra
normativa parcial e seguir em frente
exemplos disso são por exemplo dois
professores amigos meus de longa data
temos uma disciplina juntos na usp que
chama julgamento decisão escolha é o
professor marcelo vanucci professor josé
siqueira
trabalhamos juntos e eu sou muito grato
a eles por isso sua palestra dedicada a
eles
tenho o ken fujioka que também é uma
pessoa que há anos vem introduzir dentro
do caminho da divulgação científica que
é pegar o sujeito da ciência de mim
transformar num sujeito da experiência
compartilhar com vocês sou muito grato a
ele e ana que ali no fundo que também é
uma pessoa que do ponto individual
sempre me deu continência para aliar e
um espaço seguro para aliar o meu
sujeito da ciência da experiência de uma
forma mais frutífera né essa é a busca
que vocês têm que ter na busca por
sucesso não é a busca por ser bem
sucedido porque isso é uma igreja
isso é a busca por uma realidade que não
é sua que não faz sentido você tem que
minimizar o seu próprio erro e um espaço
nesse para descobrir isso
são esses espaços de partilha que são
infelizmente cada vez mais raros né
nunca vivemos numa se numa numa época em
que as pessoas foram tão bem e do catão
informadas e tão solitária é algo
surpreendentemente caiu-lhes tico né
do ponto de vista concreto mas agora
para terminar a luz de toda essa
conversa que tivemos podemos escrever
olha aquela fala do nosso amigo passaram
na verdade então podemos agora dizer que
passa dos que conhecem a gaiola onde
foram criados têm noção tem noção do
processo de escolha que foi submetido a
ele muito antes de existir então ele faz
parte de um contexto de uma estrutura
antropológica principalmente passar os
que conhecem a gaiola onde foram criados
decidem como pó essa idéia da gaiola não
é algo concreto é algo formal
você pode trabalhar com limite dessa
gaiola e é isso que eu desejo para vocês
trabalhe com limite de suas gaiolas
gente isso que vai trazer muito mais
sentido significado e valor para a vida
de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]